Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright must be
reminded that the Better Business Bureau is
not the correct agency for
dealing with containment
failures from horrible eldritch artifacts
sold by Marshall, Carter, and Dark.
Marshall, Carter, and Dark
exist at the frightening
intersection of dark, anomalous power and
unfettered capitalism.
They’re one of the most powerful groups
of interest out there, with almost unlimited
funds and an utterly ruthless desire to profit
at all costs.
The Better Business Bureau are utterly toothless
against a group of their sheer, unrelenting
power.
They can grease any palm and snap any neck.
The poor, lowly BBB would not be able to land
a hit on them.
The IRS, on the other hand, is a completely
different story…